what was going on to call your daddy
people can we talk about that oh yeah
i saw them on the screen i saw when i
walked in yeah we were talking about
because dude
that's like a show that's as big as
rogue it's so funny like that's just
america that's nice
rogan's got his like i know it's not his
biggest but it's like mentioned in the
same sentence which you shouldn't though
it's hilarious it's like rogan is like
brilliant scientists and everyone else
and then it's like leon yeah it's like
that's true but he's got a lot of smart
[ __ ]
but it's like what's number two it's
like call your daddy it's like whoa
we're in trouble
they're also in the algorithm of itunes
which is such a complete [ __ ] show but
nowhere near but they're it's probably
more popular than it
should be i haven't we've had them on
here yeah we've had them on here what do
they talk about
the the blonde girl is wicked smart is
it do they
is it about calling their actual fathers
no that would be
awesome yeah they should definitely do
that it's basically like the
relationship with like dudes and stuff
right
i think it's like them and like girls
and [ __ ] dudes and like sucking like
sometimes you got to suck a dick yeah
but um
it's like mancer's for women um yes
two attractive girls that again that
blonde is a legit
smart they were getting squeezed they
weren't getting squeezed man this from
my understanding you guys feel me i
don't know the details of the story i
know from what i know i know
that they kind of weren't anything and
then
joe and barstool was like hey come on
our platform
we'll send all the bros your way we're
gonna give give you an audience
and this is the deal and i know a lot of
people my boys busting with the boys is
over there i know how their contracts
work i've seen them
uh kfc's there i'm real i like those i'm
real friendly
i'm real friendly with barstool so i
[ __ ] with barstool
so they go we have this huge platform
here's the contract it's like a
multi-year three or four year car
the actual contract was one year seventy
five thousand dollars each
and then at the end of the year they
could renegotiate and then there's
nothing nobody knew how big it was going
to be
no bar barstool took a chance on them
gave them a platform
after a year they signed a multi-year
deal right and then
i think it's the burnett starts dating
this like hbo
head of hbo head of hbo support
whatever and that guy goes how much are
you making your show's
as big as rogan you should be making
this in this right let's get you out of
the deal
right so then they called the guy who
put the deal together who i'm
friends with and represents me who's
their agent and he goes
let's get him out of the deal and he's
like well we just signed
it's three year deal so they have to
once the three years is over we have so
much leverage
three years at 75 each or no no it was
more than that it was starting at 75
with bonuses every single year and then
the second year is i think 85 third year
should have been a hundred grand
but you can negotiate at the end i heard
they're both making between
uh like 250 to 300 000 i mean the
reality is
after a year they probably should not
sign that deal right
but they did and that's on time and then
it is what it is yeah
my thing like where where were you
before bar stool came about
where where was your platform no because
you have gotten to where you're at
without the
push of barbarous probably not because
they have such a loyal big
following right of bros who are into
this stuff so they do that contract
and then she starts staying homeboy who
doesn't know how the podcast space works
he's like you should be
making more let's get you out of the
contract you know you guys commit this
three multi-year deal
they go the agent put it together he's
like no you can't you'd file
you'd violate the contract that we
signed it's not smart to do this
then he goes we'll figure out hangs up
on my guy they fire my guy like you
don't know what you're doing fire him
knows what he's doing
and then they're in trouble now then
word gets out they're talking wme and
these other agencies to get out of the
contract
so that's why did they split up i heard
they also broke up
and then also then then her with homeboy
and then the smart girl the blonde who's
i hate to be [ __ ] right she's the brains
of the operation if the blonde leaves
that show
doesn't exist well now brunel is there
all right it shows done
nope now the blonde's doing it i think
are they doing an audition or something
to replace it
they had uh the president of barstow
went on to
the call her daddy uh instagram account
and said that
send your audition tapes to uh barstool
that's not how podcasting works i will
be sending it to you
you should do it i would absolutely be
great together i will send it to
you but this is no different than like
like when a quarterback the nfl signs a
big deal
or no you know what it is it's like
those [ __ ] those kids on lord of the
rings
yeah we knew it was going to be pretty
big you signed it's little rings the hue
the books were huge
and then the first one comes out in
success and i'm going all right we want
to restructure
lord of the rings and the whoever put
together is like no dude we knew this
was going to be big that's why we signed
you a multi-year deal you got to be
careful but we're worth more
you got to be careful what you sign and
listen
i mean they probably could have made a
lot more money if they didn't
sign the second like i understand taking
the if you're really huge
after a year you got to look at what
you're signing yeah
i mean i mean it is what like you exist
for a reason yeah i agree
bar still didn't get where they're at
off uh i've no there's no no
no i know those guys go to them they
they did what they should do as a
business
they they got a huge loyal following
that also catapulted these girls to
where they're at and those girls go
we're huge now we can do it without you
and barcelo's like yeah we don't know we
have a contract like yeah but we're
gonna go over here we'll know you have a
contract right no no no no
no [ __ ] yeah 100 100 i say sue him
kill him the president of barcelona
actually
renegotiated their deal as well and he
agreed to do
i believe it was 500 000 after each year
after the three-year contract is over
they would then receive their ip back
and then they would get a higher
percentage in march too so he was really
trying to make it work
but but yeah that's again my my boy will
compton
who busting the boys who i'm close
friends with he signed with him i i
reviewed the contract
it's not a bad deal like if they sign a
three-year deal you keep
everything after it's done you you own
the show you own ip
they're you're leasing their rights
you're basically leasing your rights
to bar stool and their platform to build
you up after three years
if you don't like the deal you can go on
you own it all sure they're not saying
we own caller daddy we own
busting with the boys no no we're using
our platform we like what you do
we want to add you to our network after
the three years if you don't like what
we do you're
free to leave these hoes just wanted to
leave early yeah
no they should go play for another team
when you sign a [ __ ] three-year deal
you don't sign it through your deal if
you're
if you're this is the problem you don't
sign a three-year deal
if you are you know if you want to be
independent i love independence right
so my whole thing is like i would stay
independent unless somebody gave me a
lot of money
that's reality someone's gonna give you
a lot of money for you to not be
independent now the difference is
barcelona built them up
correct you know it's a whole thing have
you heard of them before barstool
were they even i mean i don't know of
them now i only did four episodes prior
to bar stool picking and barstool saw
potential
put money and their and their resources
into them they got to high level yeah
which i'm proud of and again that
blonde's so smart man
and there's that's awesome there is a
time to leave i mean i was a gas digital
i like yesterday there's also time to
just
do what i was with gas digital when i
started legion skanks all those guys i'm
still friends with them
but like there's a time when you want to
be independent you go i don't have a
boss anymore
i want to you know they're not on this
coast at all gas digital but it's like
i you know there's i get what they're
saying too i don't get signing the
contract
but i get the frustration of like i
they shouldn't have signed a contract
you think they should have signed the
contract
the three-year contract yes really i
don't think they're [ __ ] without
barstool and bar stools
well the only way for them to know is
there's only one way to do that there's
only one way to know and then don't sign
the contract and find out
correct and then you come back to
barstow with your leg you don't think
they would have
fans without maybe not in the beginning
but now
not to the level not without the
marketing and the vision of the
the prez okay yeah but then you're right
but then it's also like how much do you
owe that person
they they're willing to play five
hundred thousand dollars each so a
million so seven figure contract each
plus merch martial sells a shitload of
merch i don't know what the merch deal
is
yeah you're right maybe the merchandise
is good hey who knows there's a lot of
money in merch
what you can't do is go all right we
signed the deal
and then renege on that deal and think
you're bigger than the brand you can't
do that i agree with you there that's
just bad business
your best thing is is you know well
because now they both hate each other so
the show's going why do they hate each
other
[ __ ] i don't know the blonde girl went
and she
renegotiated her deal because they have
separate contracts technically
they kind of made an agreement that they
would only renegotiate together as a
pair
but when the brunette girl sophia didn't
want to take the deal
and wanted to stick by her boyfriend the
blonde one was like
i need to save myself went and talked to
the president and bar stool and worked
out her own
but correct me if tell me if i'm wrong
the blonde one also edits the show
right so she uh edited the show she did
a lot of the marketing for it
i love how the news is like 30 million
unemployed also
call her dad you know what i mean it's a
very interesting
time you know on edge of great
depression also
call her daddy but this out is with
with anything it's like well so real
quick the the blonde girl she was
actually getting paid a little bit
a little bit more maybe quite a bit more
because she was also doing the editing
but she didn't reveal that to the
to the they didn't yeah so she didn't
want that drama but she was the
jordan the chick didn't realize that
she's doing them
staying three hours after to edit this
[ __ ] brunette it's like
ryan came to me and was like dude why
are you getting paid more the brunette
chick got lucky
yeah she she fell into this she got
lucky
and she she just tried her lock and she
lost i like both of them i'm
well the brunette got with the hbo guy
who doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing
right nice cause this turmoil and this
brunette chick i'd be willing to bet in
six months we don't know her i don't
know her name now
no i don't know he [ __ ] this girl yeah
she had a great thing here
this could have turned a tv show hbo
showtime going out shows left and right
who knows atm
could have been big could have been big
there's no girls out there like this
like what what do they do i'm confused
they're the one and only what do they do
we don't know
i love it he's like there's no one like
this what do they do again we don't know
what was what was the two the two black
girls on hbo had their own show they
started from a podcast two dope queens
two dope queens yeah
great name dope queen dope queens two
dope queens and these are i don't know
what they do but i feel like they're
like i don't know
queens but they're two white girls
they're just they're queens and their
dog
what what give them a show that's all
you need now
so i don't know how that ends hopefully
they that black girl's gonna be fine
that blonde girl is gonna be fine she
looks
[ __ ] yeah i hope you get pregnant with
hbo dude yeah poke holes in those
condoms
yeah girl as a reward for losing your
career i know man
wild if that guy breaks up with her then
she's completely they should get
back together the two girls should get
back
together and talk about it and you know
because
now they're probably going to have the
biggest audience they've ever had that's
a smart move i think that
that should go i [ __ ] up she talked to
the boyfriend
like dude kind of [ __ ] still work out
go to brunette like hey let's honor our
contract with
barstool let's write out the three years
take it from there let's do this
and they should openly how we fight we
should let a lot of the barcelo guys do
like a [ __ ] on them
it's just a way to like show that they
were wrong like to just let all the
people in barcelona just kind of jerk
off on them as a
as it's about female empowerment really
because they're choosing it right it's
not if it's your choice
they're choosing it they're saying hey
we were a little we were a little wacky
let's
lay on the floor and let everybody jizz
on us and then we'll go back to
podcasting
it's just my thoughts these are my
thoughts
if they if anybody wants to hire me as a
consultant that's cool too
dave portnoy hypes barstool sports
auditions amid call her daddy drama oh
i'm doing an audition man i'm going i'm
sure i'm gonna do an audition i'm gonna
put a wig on i'm gonna do an audition
i'd be like i'm this
i'm the [ __ ] call her daddy stop at
yes how big was that [ __ ]
yes come i
imagine that's the show i don't know i
imagine that's a good
portion of it so since cooper made 506
000 frankly received 461 000.
we can't hear this video or no in a
30-minute video but it's the first said
the infighting started as they began
renegotiating the second year of their
three-year contract
during the first year to be fair 500 600
506 000 new york's like making 30 000 in
la
it's not a lot of money it ain't a lot
of money
money goes money goes further than new
york
not much further not much further not
much but you know
you can well in texas your bill gates
but in new york it's like
bananas how much money you have to have
to have any space
i mean but you you know but that's what
you signed up for that's where you sign
up for it so i love the city i mean it's
yeah i don't want to live there but yeah
i'm done with it too i mean i lived
there for years and loved it but now i'm
like yeah i could never live there again
never and the reason is because of the
call her daddy drums
i would have lived there if the daddy
girls were treated
better knowing that they're not together
makes me want to kill myself
like i don't this is 912. we had 911 now
we have nine 12.
you got a turn of edge let me pee before
we get kind of let's
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected